but when I started building unknown I
started to think about okay wait what
did I hate about recruitment when I
worked at the gym like there were some
brilliant things I loved about Gemini
people I tell you what I loved I loved
the culture I loved the getting things
done I love being in the team together
and pulling in the same direction I
didn't like the fact that we were sort
of chucked into this office 8 AM
5 or 6 P.M every single day all these
weird trivial arguments that are
happening when you're not doing the job
that you're there to do 40 of the people
gave a about what they did the
other 60 were there to take a pay packet
and probably become an estate agent at
some point so I didn't want to be in
that room for very long I lasted six and
a half years went out on my own in this
kind of Rage I hate recruitment well
recruitment's awful but I am a recruiter